did your distributor or indie rights
give you the idea for a vampire movie or
that's something that you
came up with and pitched it to them so
um
i would say i met you know met michael
linda through frey and indy writes was
just phenomenal for that film uh and as
anybody
that's ever gone through distribution
knows it's a nightmare process when you
find a good distributor
cling to them and uh being become good
friends we're at
dinner one night and i was talking with
them and
i had recently come across a notepad
that had this kind of some notes of this
film so i was telling them about
about it just the uh initial ideas for
it
and the next day michael texted me and
basically said this should be your next
film this is something that could
actually sell um
and so i started thinking i was like
well you know
fray was great and i mean i'm fortunate
it actually made its budget back and
turned mildly profitable
off of you know fairly modest budget but
it's a film i never expected to make a
dime off of um
but if i want to actually have a career
making films i should probably do one
that
has the potential to make money you know
and so
uh so yeah i've decided uh
if i could find a way to make it work
for me that this would be the film to do
and that's when
really reflecting on it and finding you
know and it was literally right around
the time that you know story said
earlier about my grandfather past scene
happened
that i started thinking about it
from that perspective and like okay this
could actually be really interesting
um you know just feeling something
that's like you know drinks to numb the
pain
is done with their life but isn't you
know can't die
um and then on the the female side of
it um it almost sounds terrible i'm
bringing up family as inspirations for
my vampire movie um they're lovely
people
but my mother had said to me years ago
uh
when she was growing up she was you know
in the 60s being raised to be like you
know
good housewife if she had aspirations it
was to be a teacher
or a secretary um and then
you know late 60s uh women's rights and
really started to flourish and she's
like when i went off
to college all of a sudden i'm being
told i can be
anything i want to be and like i've
never thought of that before who
i don't even know who i want to be and
she's a i could go on forever she's an
amazingly talented and
smart woman who just it took really
until
later on in life before she found the
things she's really passionate about
um and by that time it was like well
i can't really make this my career i'm
in my you know
late 50s or 60s so um
it was kind of the idea of like
exploring that a woman who's from that
type of
whether culture or an era where
they were really a commodity that if
they wanted to be something it was to be
a housewife and
as kind of a servant class
how does someone like that navigate and
find her own agency
in this current climate where women are
finally allowed to have a voice finally
allowed to
make those decisions that can guide
their life and
whether those decisions are right or
wrong i mean the character in the script
makes some dumb decisions um some
decisions that she regrets
uh but she had the the
agency and the freedom to make those
choices and that's part of her
coming of her own you know into her own
and coming out of this uh
this sort of uh place where she'd been
under yuri or been a
you know villager and being able to kind
of find that navigate that but then also
learning from the examples around her
you know her
her colleague and friend is another you
know cocktail waitress who maybe isn't
the best
example of how to you know make the
right decisions in your life and so
kind of explores that idea and uh
gabriella who plays daria was just such
a
a perfect discovery for somebody to
really
encapsulate that persona
authentically she was excellent
is she eastern european because she had
a beautiful accent but
i looked at her bio it didn't say yeah
she's actually hungarian
she grew up in hungary and she's been in
the us for a while now but uh
it was actually coincidentally i didn't
know this until after i'd cast her i was
talking about some of the inspirations
for when i was writing the family i
based it loosely off the
uh elizabeth bathory and her family uh
just like infamous uh often believed to
have been a real vampire
um and found out that gabriella actually
grew up about
approximately 10 miles from their castle
so
probably you know sure ancestors of hers
had been uh
you know sacrifices to the bathrooms
back in the day so
or at least had known them so it's uh i
think she
she brought a lot of that heritage that
a really authentic heritage to the
character
um and also you know coming from a
country that politically and socially is
very different than ours
um you know something i always thought
about with my grandmother who was uh
she was also from eastern europe and
even you know all these
all those years later still like a very
reserved woman a very
thoughtful strong woman but very
reserved
in her ways like almost i mean
almost that old idea of knowing a
woman's place like she was
very much of that and for
someone coming from a different culture
where that is still a thing
um that a woman has a place
having that in this character having
that be something that she's
actively trying to grow beyond but still
struggling with that
you know i think gabby's had this
naturalness with that because she's
coming from a place that kind of still
has some of those old world
social structures and philosophies
yeah i thought she played the part
extremely well and you'd also see it in
her eyes
she'd be processing something but
wouldn't necessarily say it so you could
tell okay
she'll play the role but she's got
another trick up her sleeve and
yeah i like that too i thought that was
really well done that was a huge
challenge
for her and something i knew early on
was going to be a difficult thing for
anyone that played that roles
throughout the entire film there's only
two scenes where you see her
authentic self or three scenes i should
say always to her authentic self
for most of the movie her overt
emotions are a cover for what the
character is actually feeling
and so she really had to play that
well and um a few of the people have
seen it
the film more than once have said it's
interesting to watch it that second time
where you can
really see how she does you know
ride that line of like showing acting
the emotions that are characters
supposed to be acting but also showing
what the character is really feeling and
like you said so much of it is through
just her incredibly subtle mannerisms
her eyes um
she's a very gifted actress absolutely
and i noticed she
she should have more credits i hope she
gets more work i looked at her imdb
and i really hope she gets more roles
because she's talented we're actually
nervous about that with both her and
vanya for leads in a film uh nika who
was
so helpful in the film as well as a
supporting role uh
she and i had some talks about that in
terms like are we really entrusting in
this film to
some actors that don't have a lot of
credits and bonnie had the theater
background at least
um but you'd watch the tapes and you're
just like i just
i believed them so much and uh
you know really glad i took
that you know had that faith in them and
they had the faith in me to
you know go off to vegas for a month
into this crazy shoot
but yeah i got really fortunate with
them they're both just
phenomenal talents and i too really hope
to see them a lot more
i was joking i hope by the time we do
the sequel to this i can't afford them
we have a quote here from your executive
producer and distributor michael madison
and he's of nd rights and he put jeff
ryan
proved that he could deliver the highest
quality production value and dramatic
flair
on a budget that makes profitability
much more attainable than more directors
can deliver
so your first your first feature frey
reached what the top 15 in amazon war
films
yeah yeah warren military yeah uh fray
reached uh
it reached the top 15 war in military
films in amazon the u.s and it got to
number two
under art house independent films in the
uk
um they apparently don't have a war in
military section so they put it under in
the art house
but uh it was wild i mean i just never
expected that i mean
we were literally right below i have a
screenshot of it we were right below
apocalypse now like if we if i go above
apocalypse now on amazon i'm just going
to retire i'm never going to top that
just go out while you're ahead um but it
was wild i mean to see
our little film up do it performing
better than you know
on amazon performing better than uh hurt
locker performing better than
you know platoon these films that were
just to me iconic
uh and great films uh in
in their own right uh and i mean the uk
one
also have screen grabbed because it was
just surreal to see it was literally the
only film above it was reservoir dogs
uh wow which is just wild to see uh
so yeah and again i mean we did that
film for
so little um there's a lot of expenses
to the film that add up i mean the
festival circuit marketing promotion
sound mastering i spent a fortune on
frey i was also
a director sound man and
i'm not a great sound man so a lot of
post budget on uh
refining the sound quality and stuff
like that
um but uh but yeah it was
great to see that happen and so you know
linda and michael
not only because of that but they've
seen what i've done with the commercial
world they've seen
you know just the diversity of projects
i can do that have been
successful for clients so they know that
even though frey is my only was my only
feature at the time
that i at least have the consistency of
being able to deliver at a high
production value
for modest budgets
and so and again i'm just i'm fortunate
the fact that i fell into the world of
doing like
you know fashion web commercials and
stuff where
you know i wouldn't have the greatest
budget for my end of it
but would make it work and
um just got to constantly be shooting i
mean they have a new season every three
months so there'd be a new ad every
three months
and i was really fortunate constantly
refining that skill set
and then not having budgets always
having to get my own costumes do my own
set
design um but learning from these
commercial shoots from working with
these
you know professional production
designers professional costume designers
and all sort of stuff and so i
developed taste level for what you can
accomplish with a budget but then also
um try to apply that to my own
productions where
you know and i i enjoy that stuff i
think that's part of having that fine
arts background
helps where it's not about the medium
it's about
the overall message
you